this would prove
the most fiercely fought presidential
election in french history
the young finance minister valerie
giscardista
facing socialist leader francois
mitterrand when the votes were counted
shiskar had pulled off a remarkable
victory
beating mitara by a slender margin
of course the margin could have been
bigger but in a presidential election
what matters is the decision that you
have taken and the responsibility which
i will take on
i understand that in this campaign you
wanted change political change
economic change and social change you
will not be disappointed
the new president of the republic
described himself as a conservative who
likes change and he brought a more
liberal attitude to social issues like
divorce
contraception and abortion it was
shiskaw's initiative that brought
together leaders from west germany
italy japan and the uk and us to an
economic forum
that founded the influential g7 but gi
scandistan's relations with
other european leaders was problematic
british prime minister margaret thatcher
in her memoir said
the president jisca was not someone to
whom i
warned and i had the strong impression
that the feeling was mutual
he was regarded by downing street as
haughty and supercilious
which all did nothing to ease daily
tensions between downing street and the
elysee palace
but it was president xi destan's
relationship with this man
that would leave him badly damaged
emperor picasso crowned himself ruler of
the impoverished former french colony
central african republic in 1977
in a ceremony that cost 40 million
dollars
giscow was a frequent visitor to his
game reserve
and was accused by french media of
receiving a gift of diamonds from the
emperor
that they are going to be sold and the
revenue will be used in development work
in the central african republic
sixty-four percent of the french people
thought she scared esta
an honest and competent president but a
very distant figure
in 1981 he lost the election to meteorol
at the conclusion of his resignation
address he demonstrated he had never
lost his sense of theater and drama
as he walked away from the presidency
natasha butler al jazeera paris